my favorite number is 27 it's always
been my favorite number even when I was
before I was a mathematician before I
was properly a mathematician I guess
because 3 has got kind of three is a
magic number in some sense it's got
properties and like 3 add 3 was a bit
boring 3 times 3 still wasn't quite good
enough but then 3 to the power of 3 was
like that that'll do me so I went for 27
and I always had this idea that being 27
would be like I would totally have
everything in my life sorted by then
like the year when I was 27 would be
like awesome like a brilliant year I am
I have recently turned 27 and things are
going pretty well I'd say probably I
guess I mean three sort of the first
proper like number really like to like
ones nonsense like one doesn't really do
anything
twos just there and then three you know
three is when you start to really get
number II you know three crops up in a
lot of places it has got quite a lot of
stuff related to it the more isn't
through your favorite number well it was
at first but I realized that I was quite
derivative and that pretty much everyone
who realized how good three was would
just be like oh yeah my favorite number
is three so I decided to power it up and
go for three to the three I recently
found out that 27 is a self locating
number in the expansion of pi it
obviously starts with a three but then
the bit we're interested in is the
decimals so it's like three one four one
and so on
so these are these are just the decimal
digits of pi but if I take if I if I
count along here and of course like all
good computer scientists I start
counting at zero of course I'll
occasionally I'll find numbers which
match up with their own position in this
decimal expansion so six there is a
number which which starts at its
position six in here so if I carry on
numbering these this doesn't actually
happen and for that many numbers and in
Phi in fact if I get here I've got 27
the 27th digit there
is the beginning of the number 27
here in this decimal expansion and in
fact the next time that will happen is
at some point in pi we'll get to this
and in fact that digit there is digit
number 135 nine eight now it's the next
time that will happen so twenty-seven
pretty special what do you do for your
27th birthday I had a party and invited
all my friends and we played board games
what games we had rubik's cube themed
board game we had some maths headset
which is a matter card game and various
other fairly nerdy serious board games
but it was pretty good like we hired out
a room in a pub and just took over the
room